the anger the disdain and the contempt
we saw between Boris Johnson and Kia
stammer has disappeared after months of
parliamentary jousts about truthfulness
standards and fitness for office today
Liz truss and kyostarma parried each
other on policy the new PM arrived
colleagues even though most of them
didn't vote for her Richie sunak and his
most high profile supporters were
nowhere to be seen
instead Liz truss was flanked by her
closest cabinet allies not a white man
among them Rising energy bills is the
issue of the Autumn and today a new
dividing line was drawn over how to pay
for it the government want to borrow
billions whilst labor prefer taxing the
profits of oil and gas companies
protecting oil and gas profits and
forcing working people to pay the bill
she's the fourth Tory prime minister in
six years the face at the top may change
but the story Remains the Same
and can't she see there's nothing new
about a Tory prime minister who when
asked who pays
says it's you the working people of
Britain well there's nothing new about a
labor leader who is calling for more tax
rights
same old same old tax and spend what I'm
about
is about reducing taxes getting our
economy growing getting investment
getting new jobs for people right across
the country and it is not just the tone
that has changed but the language too
our analysis of Liz truss's answers
features the words energy and the
economy a lot as well as tax tax also
popped up a lot in Kia stalma's
questioning as well as excess profits
and working people when Boris Johnson
was PM Theresa May used to shoot spiky
questions at him she seems far fonder of
her second successor can I ask my right
honorable friend why does she think it
is but all three female prime ministers
have been conservative
it's quite extraordinary isn't he isn't
that there doesn't seem to be uh the
ability in the labor party to find a a
female leader indeed a leader who
doesn't come from North London
[Applause]
but opposition MP seemed Keen to toxify
his trust as fast as possible the Prime
Minister may have changed Mr Speaker but
it's the same old being shouted down by
the attorneys going to be as useless and
corrupt as a predecessor who's
profitable
people in pontyprid will never forget
that she played a key role in a
government that failed Millions Liz
trust did do pretty well today but it
will be more tricky to repeat that
performance if her big interventions on
the economy and energy bills do not work
now sources suggest the labor leaders
team wanted to prevent him falling into
the same trap that some say Rishi sunak
slipped into during leadership debates a
man splitting Atlas truss and after
today's session secure congratulated the
PM on her debut they will be head to
head again tomorrow when Liz truss
announces her long-awaited and much
needed support package on Rising energy
bills